I need 11 000 votes give me a break
that's a quote that many of us remember
that relates to Georgia that was during
a phone call that the failed twice
indicted twice impeached former
president had on the phone with Georgia
officials saying I only need 11 000
votes to defeat Joe Biden give me a
break let's find those votes Trump
claims he was saying just I think I won
let's just find the legal votes every
other sane person in the world who heard
the audio tape says no Trump's trying to
coerce and say find a way for me to win
even if Joe Biden actually won it turns
out that it was not only in Georgia that
Trump was doing this and this once again
fits this theme we get one report and
many of his Defenders say so out of
character he would never do this we now
have two independent unrelated reports
Washington Post exclusive report from
our friendly Ann Caldwell from the uh
Community Radio Days Josh dossey and
Yvonne winget Sanchez Trump pressured
Arizona governor Doug Ducey to overturn
the 2020 election it's it reads just
like the Georgia story but it's a
different story in a phone call in late
2020 Trump tried to pressure Republican
Arizona governor Doug Ducey to overturn
the state's presidential election
results saying that if enough fraudulent
votes could be found it would overcome
Trump's narrow loss in Arizona according
to three people familiar with the call
Trump also repeatedly asked vice
president Mike Pence to call Ducey and
prod him to find the evidence to
substantiate Trump's claims of fraud
Pence called Ducey several times to
discuss the election
they said though he did not follow
Trump's directions to pressure the
governor the extent of Trump's efforts
to cajole Ducey into helping him stay in
power has not before been reported even
as Trump's other efforts have been made
public Ducey told reporters in December
2020 that he and Trump had spoken but
declined to disclose the contents of the
call although he disagreed with Trump
about the outcome of the election Ducey
has sought to avoid a public battle from
Trump notably Ducey did not record the
call according to people familiar with
the matter so we now have yet another
story we have now heard if you look
nationally from County election
officials
state election officials state
legislators we have heard from all of
these different levels about a very
specific sort of plan
we know that there were elements to this
attempted coup that went all the way to
the White House it included the January
6 rioters the halls of Congress fake
electors in various States pressure
phone calls attempts to commandeer
voting machines remember every one of
these little details would have been a
crisis if Obama had done it that's for
sure
but they are just yet another instance
when it comes to Trump there was that
period right after the elections where
Trump said sequester the voting machines
get voting machines
officials went to Trump and said what
are you talking about we can't really do
that what do you mean just bring them
here to the White House it doesn't make
any sense we at this point can make a
couple of conclusions number one these
people were not randomly acting alone
you didn't randomly have
fake electors in Arizona and fake
electors in Wisconsin all trying to do
the same thing just by Miracle incidents
it is obvious that this was a concerted
and coordinated effort number two
some of the same tactics and techniques
were attempted in multiple States the
pressure phone calls were attempted in
Georgia and the pressure phone calls
were attempted in Arizona now the
questions that remain and I don't
pretend to have the answers at this time
we just don't know
is special prosecutor Jack Smith looking
into what we just learned about from
Arizona is it possible that this will
become part of his investigation or is
this being independently investigated at
the state level in Arizona much like
fonnie Willis is investigating the same
in Georgia from which we will soon know
the outcome sometime between next week
and early September we don't know the
answer to that but what is abundantly
clear is that this was a concerted
effort loony Lindsey Graham seemed to
have been involved in multiple places by
the way Lindsay brutally booed at a
trump rally over the weekend we'll talk
about that in a moment that's the latest
and it is crimes crimes and more crimes
if you've been getting crushed in the
markets lately like many people have you
were probably happy to hear that
treasury yields have been surging right
now you can get a five percent yield on
treasury bills Which is higher than most
high-yield savings accounts I've seen
and unlike a high-yield savings account
treasury bills are a fixed rate asset so
so you know what you're getting at the
time of purchase but buying U.S
treasuries can be very complicated or at
least it was because our sponsor
public.com lets you buy treasury bills
in seconds right from your phone and put
your cash to work keep in mind that
treasury bills are government-backed
securities considered one of the safest
Investments around when you buy them on
public they are securely stored at the
Bank of New York Mellon the world's
largest custodian bank and Security
Services Company plus there are no
minimum hold periods or settlement
delays you can access funds anytime if
you keep it invested public will
automatically roll over your Investments
at maturity so you have one thing you
don't have to think about go to
public.com Pacman to start getting that
five percent yield on your cash the link
is down below